[Música]
y
muchas gracias por tenerme aquí el día
de hoy me toca hablar sobre la
optimización del arte
esto es muy importante porque
últimamente ha habido como un burbujeo
acerca de estos archivos que de pronto
archivos digitales que se hacen llamar
nfc o enertis y me parece muy muy
inteligente muy interesante y una
situación que va a modificar de alguna
manera lo que estamos viviendo y la
manera en la que nos relacionamos con el
arte y con la cultura primero que nada
quiero explicarles un poco qué es un ene
efe que es un archivo digital único
inmutable un punto que no fungible
es importante hablar un poco de lo que
esto conlleva a partir de la generación
de las cripto monedas y de toda esta
situación hubo un cambio de paradigmas y
de entendimiento a partir de un
protocolo ojo un nfc no es una no es una
técnica artística
no es un formato si es un protocolo para
guardar
archivos digitales y tener posesión de
ella es una posesión digital que sea muy
segura
es muy interesante porque finalmente yo
sigo usando hojitas para hablar aunque
hable de d
y alta tecnología
nfc como les digo es un protocolo y a mí
me dirán por qué está tan interesado en
esto si lo mío es el arte no bueno yo
pienso que el arte es experiencia
primariamente independientemente de los
niveles que evidentemente lleva la
historia
los aparatos legitimadores el mercado
etcétera pero a mí no me interesa ni
hablar a gente que ya está como muy
profundamente metido en esto ni tampoco
me interesa hablarles de si son buenas
inversiones del dinero a mí me interesa
la cultura me interesa el arte y me
interesa compartir con ustedes sobre
todo con la gente que no está
relacionada con esto un poco un poco de
mi experiencia por eso he decidido
dividir en mi presentación en dos una
parte para pues para hablar de los
procesos que me llevaron a tomar estas
decisiones de hablar de esto en este día
y por otro lado para tratar de explicar
de una forma lo más sencillo posible por
qué
como decían mis maestros en la escuela
si si tu abuelita lo puede entender
entonces está bien espero que
que así sea bueno
esto que vemos atrás es una pintura yo
soy pintor originalmente siempre quise
ser artista y ser pintor mi abuelo era
pintor así que tuve la facilidad de
llegar a un lugar que ya estaba montado
y de que mis padres me me empujara nada
blemente para que hiciera lo que yo
quisiera y pues decidí terminar aquí no
esto es una pintura hecha con acrílico
por acá está la imagen mía para dar
cierto contexto y específicamente esto
tiene la finalidad de entender como un
artista que se dedica a las artes
y estudia tiene digamos ciertas
capacidades
técnicas se mueve y no es que me mueva
por completo pues se mueven con una
parte digital no esta es una pieza una
pieza y con un piano una pieza de un
piano intervenido en una galería
esta es otra pieza este es una pintura
son pinturas que hago en capas porque me
interesa ya lo veremos más adelante
hacer una recorrido entre las diferentes
imágenes y hacer
de alguna manera un contexto entre una y
otra a partir de toda esta situación
digital me interesaba hacer
hipervínculos relacional así como cuando
pican en un link en el en el internet y
te lleva a otro lugar así me interesaba
hacer las cosas con los libros porque
finalmente todo lo que vemos en internet
está escrito toda esa información está
escrita y me pareció que había mucha
relación con los libros
esto es lo mismo y empecé a hacer esto
es muy similar a lo del piano y entonces
empecé a meter esta parte del lenguaje
del libro etcétera hasta llegar a estas
situaciones como arquitectónicas no
aquí una una imagen de alguna manera que
compacta un poco lo he estado hablando y
de pronto piensas que van hacia otro
lugar porque porque también he trabajado
haciendo mucho trabajo conceptual sobre
todo con el cuerpo esto es una obra en
49 días con el uso de sustancias
modifique mi cuerpo
este es unos dibujos sobre sobre el
mismo cuerpo del brazo de la barba las
cejas el pelo del pecho y lo dibujé con
una pluma de vic se llama simulation y
trata de eso de lo mismo de qué habla el
arte de la simulación
una pieza más para tratar de expresarme
mi
felicidad por la libertad aquí me puse
unas placas de titanio
adentro de
la barbilla con la única intención de
expandir mis fronteras también
de la libertad
casi terminando bueno una pieza de
se llama
un nonato me quite el ombligo para
tratar de hablar de la inmortalidad
porque el arte habla normalmente
con metáforas y con alegorías
acercándome un poco ya esta parte
digital un boceto hecho a mano
de una pieza que quería hacer quería
contener el aliento y capturarlo de
alguna forma entonces que hice bueno fui
a un tomógrafo llene la cavidad bucal y
con un tomógrafo escanea mi aliento y
tuve 22 productos en este
una imagen donde se ve claramente la
cavidad llena de aire y luego tome ese
objeto y lo mande a imprimir físicamente
al 350 por ciento qué es esto que
tenemos aquí una burbuja de aire adentro
de una boca
que hice en el 2006 bueno ya me estoy
acercando un poco a lo que realmente es
mi interés empecé a trabajar este tipo
de de piezas que son multiplayer con la
intención de que la gente pudiera jugar
con ellas y pudiera cambiar los ángulos
y de pronto pudieran hacer algo que
ahorita está muy de moda que se llama
arte generativo y en el arte digital y
de alguna manera han marcado los
energías porque es una forma en la que
los lakers pueden ser elegidos para
generar una pieza sin embargo aquí están
ya mis incursiones en el mundo de las
descripto imágenes y todo sin embargo
uno no elige las imágenes que saldrán
esto está muy interesante porque de esta
manera el artista selección a lo que
puede determinar la computadora y el
paso final lo hace la computadora al
momento que hace un mini de estas piezas
que es lo que sucede qué
hay una colaboración entre el artista y
el espectador
bueno ahora sí empezamos un poco no
todas las artes han tenido las mismas
suertes si hablamos con nuestro vecino
con algún amigo que probablemente no
hable o no conozca mucho de artes
visuales y preguntamos sobre música
estoy seguro que sabrás habrá ritmos
habrá artistas sabala composiciones
podrá hablarnos hasta de fechas porque
pues porque la música tuvo una
posibilidad que algunas otras artes no
tuvieron en su momento y que finalmente
se empiezan a democratizar la música
tuvo como compañero al fonógrafo a los
tracks en lp a los casettes etcétera y
ahora las plataformas digitales esto nos
da algo espectacular porque la gente ha
vivido con música porque ha tenido el
chance de vivir con esto no entonces a
partir de esto es que de pronto se
llenan estadios
y bueno esta misma suerte pasó con él
con la fotografía cuando llegó la
fotografía modificó todo por ejemplo el
cine parte de este este punto y a partir
de esto es que tuvimos bhs es dvds
etcétera ellos aquí se van a de pronto
un poco alejado de lo que estamos
pensando ahorita como súper alta
tecnología pero es un momento así lo fue
entonces cuando hablamos del arte hay
que entender para qué funcionaba el arte
el arte las artes visuales
específicamente la pintura que en algún
momento funcionó para evangelizar la
gente no sabía leer y muchas iglesias
utilizada en esto para poder relacionar
la gente con ciertos textos por otro
lado la monarquía la corona la burguesía
o para ciertos eventos históricos fue
importantísima la pintura cosa que fue
sustituida posteriormente por la foto
después la foto cumplir con esta función
de forma quizá más inmediata y bueno la
fotografía tuvo esta situación de
terminar finalmente este documentando
muchos eventos y le costó un poco de
trabajo entrar al mundo del arte hasta
mediados más o menos de de del siglo 20
es que ya empezaban a la primera mitad
finales la primera mitad ya estaba mucho
más relacionado pero que cambió con esto
también cambió directamente la pintura y
con ello todas las artes todas las
vanguardias del siglo 20 fueron
modificadas a partir de la foto
y a dónde voy con esto bueno con el uso
de estas tecnologías que se garantice el
nfc permite que una persona tenga un
archivo digital y tenga posesión
completa de la pieza sin que puedan
piratear sela sin que de alguna manera
la gente la pueda bajar y de alguna
forma esto democratiza el arte y reduce
de alguna manera esto que se llamaba
contracultura que era cuando alguien
estaba haciendo cultura pero no estaba
dentro del establishment hoy los
espacios digitales y la gente que
produce en éxtasis la incluso las redes
sociales han ayudado en gran medida a
que las artes visuales estén más al
alcance de la gente porque yo recuerdo
en algún momento de mis años
de la primera la segunda mitad de los 20
que la gente no entendía por qué me
dedicaba al arte quiso la gente que
estaba muy especializada tiene el chance
de poder platicar con ellos hoy pienso
que eso se ha reducido en gran medida y
de pronto en plataformas como tumblr que
ha desaparecido o como instagram han
funcionado de alguna manera
y democratizando esto a los ojos de un
público que quizá no es un público
conocedor y de ahí hay un paso para
poder entrar quizás de pronto ir a un
show en un museo o
para poder entender un poco más lo que
está sucediendo no todo esto no no de
alguna manera no sustituye es decir
cuando ustedes acceden a un sprint no
sustituyen las pinturas no sustituyen
las esculturas sin embargo dan la
posibilidad de que haya una lateralidad
en las artes sin embargo hay artistas
que siempre han trabajado en esto en
artes visuales y por ejemplo en tumblr
había gente que subía muchos gibbs y
desarrollaron realmente un tipo de
trabajo artístico muy muy sustentable
muy sólido que no tenía salida porque no
había posición de digital garantizada
nadie iba a pagar por un gif y hay
grandes artistas que durante mucho
tiempo sobre todo la primera década del
siglo del siglo 21 y un siglo anterior
donde la computación estaba muy fuerte
y empezaba el internet este pues no
podían vivir de esto hoy de alguna forma
este panorama ha cambiado y qué es lo
que nos trajo aquí bueno en el 2021
específicamente un artista vendió una
pieza en 69 millones de dólares con una
pieza que son imágenes digitales y es
justamente aquí donde nos damos cuenta
de que este protocolo si funciona porque
si no esa pieza habría desaparecido ya
hace mucho tiempo se habría bajado de lo
que llaman boxing que es de la misma
manera en la que funciona habitan y
etéreo en algunas otras
cripto monedas simplemente se utilizó la
tecnología para hospedar una imagen y de
esta manera democratizar lo hay muchas
dudas al respecto cuando se habla de
dinero cosa que a mí no me interesa
tanto no de pronto vemos este número t
pero por otro lado esto de alguna manera
está permitiendo que la gente consuma
mucho más alta y no no me refiero al
consumo económico pienso que hay dos
tipos de consumo un consumo intelectual
que para mí es el más importante y
posteriormente si alguien quiere pagar
que es importante porque los artistas
vivimos de la misma manera que vive un
abogado o un vendedor este pueden vender
las piezas entonces hoy de alguna forma
algunas personas que están intentando
quizá hacer una carrera como artistas o
artistas importantes ya no le están
dando tanto peso a ciertos espacios
aunque los espacios como los museos y
las galerías y todo si legitima en
cierta parte del comportamiento de las
artes por otro lado estamos viendo gente
que surge de pronto en una red social y
sin pasar por un aparato legitimador
como la galería o el museo o el centro
cultural termina haciendo una venta de
esta magnitud y posteriormente
evidentemente el museo la galería el
espacio cultural lo adopta a mí me
parece que esto es muy muy importante y
hay tres libros básicos que yo
recomiendo al respecto no son libros
nuevos porque no hablan necesariamente
de la tecnología son libros más
relacionados a la filosofía y unos de la
ligereza de filipovski un libro que nos
acerca a la manera en la que
hoy se nos presenta
toda la vida cotidiana de manera más
fácil aunque tenga una carga tecnológica
muy fuerte o culturalmente muy fuerte
otros apocalípticos e integrados eso es
lo que hablaba que esto no desaparecen
las las pinturas y que nadie se tenga
que poner este un grito en el cielo esas
van a seguir pintando en los artistas
pero algunos de ellos decidieran por
otro camino este es de umberto eco y el
último es de el del medio es el mensaje
creo que es muy correcto tomar este
texto de marchamalo luján porque
justamente
aunque el medio es un medio digital la
red está generando esta posibilidad de
entender la posesión y el protocolo de
seguridad que nos permite generar
comunidades y otro tipo de públicos por
último y no menos importante quiero
decirles que de pronto
he visto esta comunidad tan activa como
no he visto a otros a diario hay al
menos en los canales que yo sigo 67
charlas al día de gente de la comunidad
y eso es solo a las que yo estoy escrito
en el que este tipo de foros como los
que estamos ahorita están pasando como
les digo cinco o seis veces al día y se
juntan para hablar de diferentes temas
que está sucediendo aquí que le es tan
relevante a los jóvenes ya los no tan
jóvenes como yo es algo que para mí
vale la pena poner la atención porque si
no de alguna forma quedaremos rezagados
de alguna manera
digamos que como conclusión pienso que
está el chance de abrir nuevas
posibilidades
a áreas laterales que permitan a la
gente tener el chance de exhibir y de
levantar la voz sin necesidad de ir a la
institución y por último quiero
agradecer a todos
de esta conferencia a mis padres que
hace un par de meses
desafortunadamente se fueron muchas
gracias por el espacio buenas tasas